foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
our family has been through a lot
together
you told me that when I was 10. I was in
a coma but I don't remember being sick
we're ready to forget
ever since then I see crazy stuff with
my dreams
those are not dreams
it's happening again something is
following us
I'm gonna need you to remain still
well
hello
[Music]
the further you travel
the riskier the journey becomes
you visit or not you want to turn right
my Mom leaves at nine so you're ten
it's where'd you get it from anyway
apparently was the hand of someone who
could connect to the dentist
[Music]
the other hand's just out there
white people [__] man I tell you all
right let's do this
[Applause]
Drew say talk to me
talk to me
what if we open the door but we didn't
shut it
we have to do something you want to do
it again
[Applause]
I'm not gonna stop
what was it
I let you in I let you in
oh my God
thank you
all right
[Music]
options
foreign
[Applause]
was still available yes the security
guard I will take anything
this place was huge in the 80s with the
kids they shut it down years ago the
owner's just not ready to let it go yet
I will work and you will sleep I
understand
all you have to do
is keep your eyes on the monitor
welcome to Freddy Fazbear's where
fantasy and fun come to life
okay
[Music]
[Applause]
we must be new security guard can I help
you officer have you met them yet
[Applause]
who
damn
[Music]
in the 80s kids went missing
the police searched Freddy's top to
bottom hello
[Music]
they never found them
that's why the place shut down
there are ghost children possessing
giant robots
thanks for the heads up
technically they're animatronics
what do they want they want to make her
like them Bobby
tell me how to stop them
it's too late
Bobby go
where to
why do I always get the weirdos
[Music]
it's okay it was just a bad tree
I heard it again
no more nightmares tonight okay champ
foreign
this is getting ridiculous
this is an old house
there's bound to be bumps in the night
[Music]
Peter Drew this yes is he all right
Peter has an overactive imagination
[Music]
no more that's right
you know I wish I had someone I could
talk to about the things that were
happening in my house Mom
[Music]
[Applause]
mom
[Music]
Peter sometimes
you have to make hard decisions to
protect your family
what is that
the banging
[Music]
you don't hear anything Peter
it's going to get you into trouble one
day
[Music]
it's been through
for what happened to her you mean how
West her brainwasher and made her come
after us no one's blaming till for that
no one
doctor and Taylor yes we need him in
custody ASAP I checked the DNA we got
from
a hottest strain of tea virus in it
you're kidding I found the connection
between the folks that were infected
they all visited Alcatraz
well Dr Taylor
it's time we debuted our
creation
they turn fast and without being bitten
I'm Rebecca what do you want me to tell
them someone accessed the dod server
they managed to steal data on Leon Jill
Chris and Claire you think this might
have something to do with the Opera on
now
most likely
I'm going to use my virus to clean the
Slate
Dylan
you're nothing more than pause
[Music]
excuse me
it's all yours
final stage now that there is no justice
well it's over now
[Music]
time to light you up let's do it all of
us
definitely going on vacation after this
wait
I should warn you before you step inside
the house this could change the course
of your entire life I'm not afraid of a
couple goes
you say that now
this Mansion is unhinged
these ghosts definitely don't want to
leave
death lurks around every corner
give us a break there's so many bad
people in the world haunt them amen
I do like surprises is anybody else
seeing this
we're gonna fight whether we like it or
not or else we're stuck here for
eternity
if this comes down to an exorcism
but there's always room
for one more
Tran was mugged he was tall he had hair
that was sticking out of a what a top
hat yup Top Hat yes yeah yeah it's like
top half you would pull a rabbit out of
it probably uh eyes they were a bit uh
like a raccoon when they sit back
and he was smiling like yeah like that
exactly is this the man who mugged you
wow you just did that just now
no matter how busy you ever got you
always found time for me
I can't believe I'm never gonna speak
when I was just a little girl I asked my
mother what is this Danny
[Music]
here's what she said
to me
it's me
don't let it take my babies
[Music]
oh yeah yeah you know how to fight kids
mom Mommy's let the maggots down
any
meaning
you
[Music]
everyone who ever lived here Falls
victim to some tragedy
like her daughter a year ago
my daughter was my whole life
to hear her voice again
I would give all I have
foreign
if someone wants to be heard
[Music]
we are here
that woman called the spirits and they
answered
you saw what I thought for once in your
life admit that you were up against
something bigger than you
tonight we are all afraid
we cannot hide from our ghosts
whether they are real or not
laughs
I don't normally get visits from former
students
I just I needed to tell you
how sorry I am for um about what
happened
[Music]
sorry uh let me just answer that
hello
what wait slow down
oh my God that's horrible is he
[Music]
really okay
someone just assaulted our vice
principal in the parking lot
oh my God no what are you doing what are
you doing assistant what you want you
don't know me
what are you doing this
because Randy I have been watching you
you are 20 years old and you are already
more pathetic than every person in this
God forsaken town and then bugs me
there's something about you this
foreign
[Music]
waiting for me to kill you
that was the only thing I believed
that if I'm gonna help you then I can't
ever get in my way
because it forces me
to hurt you
[Music]
I need you to work with me not against
me
I don't do this I'm doing this for you
all good
[Music]
you square
we're Square
[Music]
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
I thought that was just an old ghost
story where do you think those stories
come from
I don't know maybe she's still alive
I have to tell someone what we could
call the cops
going on here
you can't be what are you doing
when there are scary things we don't
understand
our minds try to fill in the blanks
Sometimes the best thing to do is to
face it so this light is going to be
completely solid like it is right now
and gradually it's going to start
flashing until it's totally dark
so you can see that there's nothing to
be afraid of
okay
see that's not so scary is it
just you your sister and me
okay
[Music]
it's all just in your head
Katie or something in my room
you believe me
don't you
there's no such thing as monsters you
need to grow up
I'm serious Sawyer I need to be alone
you're both having these manifestations
[Music]
you have to listen to me okay
I'm listening
sweetheart let me handle
thank you
[Music]
the Demeter on Charter from Romania to
London
shipping private crates
contents unknown
out at Sea with no land in sight
foreign
animals
all the livestock this looks like a bite
so it's the ship everywhere
evil isn't bored
[Music]
powerful evil
everything
[Music]
in night it drinks our blood he is here
we call him Dracula
he's coming
you see the size of that bloody thing
[Music]
he is on this ship which means that we
will never leave
the devil is real
may God have mercy on us all
thank you
could I get two glasses of tempranio
please it is very very bad luck to open
a bottle of wine and not finish it do
you do this a lot do what pick up sad
and Confused women in the farthest
reaches of Little Haiti only ones as
gorgeous and interesting as you
[Music]
I've got a lot of things going on I just
want to get to know you I've been
getting these blackouts I'm left for
this really strange sentence
die over over you're safe
you're here with me
it feels like I'm not seeing all of you
you know everything about me do I
[Music]
we're definitely seeing an acceleration
of memory loss I just think I can really
help you through this transition
sweetheart what if I could give you the
perfect life that you always wanted
wouldn't you want that I need some time
to think I just hope you figure it out
before it's too late
she'll do anything to keep you from
blackouts the headaches they're only
getting worse right
I feel like I'm losing my mind
why would you do it
because we're meant to be together
it's gonna be
perfect
guys are you sure this place is creepy
you guys will be fun got some big plans
you expect me to cut my hand to bring
some vigilante ghosts back from his
grave man you crazy
play the damn game
[Music]
I saw them die
there were nothing but ragdollster
what do you know about devil real the
children's ghost story Moscow stories
of some basis and Truth The Deadly night
happened right out there yeah you're
Michaels
ball
the witch brought him back from the dead
to seek his Revenge come home come home
the bloodline of all involved pause
my bloodline
from home to us
I wanted to summon the so-called
Boogeyman of the sound
play the game
some have dubbed him the Lua The Keeper
of the graveyard The Giver of Life and
the master of the Dead
foreign
[Music]
wanna die
you've sacrificed the person you deemed
the blackest guys I can prove him not
the blackest prove it I thought black
Twitter was a type of seasoning I like
Jimmy Fallon without the roots and wrong
I voted for Trump
what
twice
your time is up it's time to die
car cops
[Music]
[Applause]
we need a plan we need to get some
weapons
wait chili powder girl what I'm gonna do
cook sorry
I gotta save everyone on the damn time
[Music]
can we just go lock the doors get down
I'll be right back
[Applause]
[Music]
father Gabriella amort
on the night of June 4th
you performed an exorcism
that was not an exorcism
the majority of cases do not require an
exorcism
98 I recommend and buy him to doctors
and psychiatrists
the other two percent
I call it
evil
we have more questions for you father
Mort you have a problem with me you talk
to my boss
they pull
there's a case
that needs your attention
bring me the priest
I'm here to help Julia
wrong right
take caution their secrets buried there
it's about the concealer
the church escort against this demon
before
the Vatican covered it up we need to
find out why
you've been played you told debate
whatever you do you only do because God
allows him
imagine what could happen if the devil
possessed the soul of the Pope's
Exorcist who will defend
my faith
does not require defense
well it looks like this is home for the
night
goddamn wind
Clarence
local officials have declared a
Statewide emergency as these
unprecedented storms continue to rain
sure got a Bus full of prisoners heading
our way got caught in the storm and need
a place to hunker down until it's safe
watch on your best behavior while we're
here
straight you're in my house now I will
not hesitate to shoot you if I have to
y'all don't think this is crew and
unusual right here
alligator got in your damn police
station storm brought him in could be
infested with them by now if you want to
survive the night we're gonna have to
find a way to get along keep an eye on
him that's a Bonafide cop killer right
there
we're all gonna get eaten alive
he got one shot Sheriff
here to taste like chicken
[Music]